so like with recent news about Target
losing 9 billion dollars in a week after
having a section for the pride month and
the close and transgender and wait a
minute what just happened why did they
lose nine billion dollars anyway why did
Bud Light just lose 28 of sales and it's
not even slowing down and all of a
sudden they're coming back saying no no
no we we love our Drinkers and we're not
going to do this dilemma of anything and
then ESG comes out and says oh you guys
had a perfect score Anheuser-Busch but
after the way you handled yourself with
Dylan Mulvaney we are lowering your
score and they're so scared what
happened to CEOs number one customer
being the buyer you and I then their
employees then the investors today these
S P 500 companies why are they so scared
of BlackRock why are they so scared of
their ESG scores we're going to take a
deep dive into that topic in this video
all right so if you get value from this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel let's get right into it
what is ESG ESG is a score to measure
how well a Company addresses risks with
respect to environmental social and
governance hence ESG issues in its
day-to-day work-in operations these
risks include matters like carton
emissions employee safety and board
diversity the system uses analysts and
algorithms to calculate environmental
social and governance ratings that are
then combined into a score so where did
ESG come from in 2006 the United Nations
enacted the principles for responsible
investment PRI PRI is a set of six
principles that outline how investors
can integrate environmental social and
governance yes she factors into the
investment decisions the PRI has been
signed by over ready 3 000 investors
representing over 40 trillion dollars in
assets under management these are the
six principles of the PRI number one
incorporate ESG issues into our
investment analysis and decision making
process number two seek to ensure that
our investment activities are aligned
with our commitments to responsible
investment number three disclose our
investment policy and procedures in
relation to responsible investment
number four encourage investment
managers to incorporate ESG issues into
their decision-making process number
five to work with investee companies to
promote responsible business practices
investee meaning companies that they
invested in to investee companies number
six promote the PRI within the
investment community and with other
stakeholders so wait U.N as in like
United Nations United Nations yes what
what the hell does United Nations has to
do with the way bud light or Target or
other businesses on s p do business well
this is how they have had the choke hold
on companies to get them to hit a score
so they do what United Nation wants them
to do which is what a lot of people in
America are worried saying wait a minute
why not just worry about America who the
hell are those guys to tell us how we
live our lives how we run our companies
that's what happens when companies
global companies some of these companies
want more control and even go deeper
into how much control United Nations U.N
has over these companies so un has
powers to influence the flow of capital
and sent International laws companies
need Capital you have a high score you
get Capital you have a low score we're
not giving you the capital you want
number one legislative powers the U.N
can pass resolutions that impose
sanctions on or invest in sustainable
development projects control number two
judicial power the international court
of justice icj can impact the rights of
investors and ability of countries to
regulate the flow of capital more
control number three Financial Powers
the UN has influence over the world bank
and the international monetary fund
which have the power to lend money to
countries and to influence the flow of
capital more control the UN has several
ways to influence these institutions
including the U.N general assembly and
the security Council can pass
resolutions that are binding on the
World Bank and the IMF the U.N can
appoint the representatives to the
boards of World Bank and the IMF the UN
can provide funding to World Bank and
the IMF the unkn issue reports on
studies that can make recommendations to
the World Bank and the IMF so the next
question would be is there somebody
above the UN who is above the U.N who
controls the UN well let's take a look
ngos have the most significant influence
on the un's decision-making process
ngo's non-governmental organizations
through Lobby and advocacy and
Partnerships ngos have massive influence
over the un's agenda they also have
played a significant role in mobilizing
public opinion on U.N related issues the
NGO that encouraged the UN to enact the
principles for responsible investment
PRI was a United Nations environment
program Finance initiative or unep fi is
a partnership between the UN environment
program and the financial community so
having said that some of the largest
ngos today include Amnesty International
Revenue was roughly 392 Million last
year Doctors Without Borders they had a
two billion dollar Revenue World
Wildlife Fund they have a revenue of 256
257 million Oxfam 119 million dollars
save the children 950 million dollars
and so now the next question would be so
who controls uh the UN ngos now who
controls ngos let's take a look Top
donors so who are these top donors well
governments Netherlands Norway Sweden
and Switzerland are the top individual
donors into the une PFI so financial
institutions such as AXA BMP Deutsche
Bank HSBC ing these financial
institutions provide funding to une PFI
through their membership fees and
through their participation in various
programs and initiatives foundations
such as Ford Foundation Rockefeller
foundation and the William and Flora
Hewlett Foundation these foundations
provide funding through their grants and
through their participations in various
programs and initiatives you ready for
the next one this one's kind of weird
ready Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
has donated billions of dollars to
various ngos worldwide and partnered
with ngos like the World Health
Organization UNICEF and many others
George Soros open Society Foundation HRC
according to open Society Foundation
website the organization has given a
total of 100 million dollars to HRC over
the past 10 years which has been used to
support a wide range of organizations
work including legal challenges to
anti-lgbtq laws public education
campaigns about lgbtq issues and
lobbying efforts for lgbtq rights
legislation but if you're wondering how
big open Society Foundation is which
showers give 100 million dollars to he's
given to them since 1984 32 billion
dollars of his own money Source his own
money 32 billion dollars has been given
to open Society it's a massive ran by
George Soros so it's crazy right you
think about all these big organizations
why do they care so much what these
companies do why do why do they fear
with this ESG score some why are they
doing so many things that makes no sense
why would Bud Light Target a transgender
audience they don't drink your beer you
have military why would you make such
dumb decisions because they're worried
about pleasing the score here's a story
from Bloomberg regarding BlackRock and
Larry Fink watch this in 2020 Larry Fink
declared that a fundamental reshaping of
global capitalism was underway and that
his firm would help lead it by making it
easier to invest in companies with
favorable environmental and social
practices our flows continue to grow and
dominate things said regarding ESG funds
on the same conference call with
analysts he added BlackRock is a leader
in this this being ESG and we are seeing
the flows and I continue to see this big
shift in investor portfolios what think
did not say is that BlackRock drove a
significant part of that shift by
inserting its primary ESG fund into
popular and influential model portfolios
offered to investment advisors who use
them with clients across North America
the huge flows from such models mean
many investors got into an ESG vehicle
without necessarily choosing one as a
specific investment strategy or even
knowing that their money has gone into
one in short and a pair on BlackRock LED
Rush of investors into ESU in the past
two years has been something of
self-fulfilling prophecy at least when
it comes to the biggest such fund on the
planet a BlackRock exchange traded fund
that trades under the ticker esgu
according to data from BlackRock and
Morningstar so do you support ESG you do
you watch any sport ESG do you have
mutual funds do you have stocks have you
to some of these funds you may not know
but a portion of your money is
supporting ESG and you don't even know
it that's what this is kind of talking
about by the way let me give you some
numbers on how powerful it is and why
company CEOs S P 500 CEOs shiver when it
comes down to these types of things
watch this number one Net Zero asset
managers initiative launch in December
2020 with an initial group of 30
signatories by the end of 2022 it had
291 representing over
66 trillion dollars of assets under
management it's a lot of money 66
trillion dollars according to Larry
Fink's 2023 CEO letter today's Global
Financial assets total is 400 trillion
it's a 66 trillion that's a lot of
influence according to Boston Consulting
Group asset managers control roughly 60
percent of global investable assets this
is why companies are afraid of going
against ESG asset managers control
investment flows there is no other way
to say it but why is CEO of a company
that knows who 99 of us customers are
wants to Pander to this because behind
closed doors that guy is scared I'm not
getting a good score here how weird
right three companies I want you to know
about BlackRock State Street and
Vanguard these three companies the
amount of power they have with ESG it's
wild here's an article from Harvard
Business Review look what it says here
one of either BlackRock Vanguard or
State Street is the largest shareholder
in 88 of the S P 500 companies let me
say this one more time in case I said it
too fast one of three State Street
Vanguard BlackRock is the largest
shareholder in 88 of s p 500 companies
did you catch that that's a lot of
control and influence they are the three
largest owners of the most Dow 30
companies overall institutional
investors which may offer both active
and passive funds on 80 percent of all
stocks and S P 500 companies The Big
Three collectively held a median stake
of 21.9 percent in S P 500 companies
which represented a proportion of 24.9
percent of the votes casted at annual
meetings of those companies that would
make sense it's not these poor CEOs that
were bashing and trashing they didn't do
anything they're just reporting to their
boss who owns 24.9 of the votes they get
to impact their weight and got imagine
who's sitting in this board right and
they're like well here's what we're
thinking about we're thinking about
making something to Target to get more
families to come by and make a drink for
veterans because we kind of want to do
this no we're gonna do this and if you
guys go against this we can't fund your
this oh what do you think I'm kind of
going with these guys I still want my
job what do you think you were with me
when we talked yesterday at dinner and
you said it was a good idea I don't know
what dinner you're talking about I'm
gonna go why he doesn't want to get
fired you don't think these types of
things happen being closed doors what do
you think what do you think when you
have this kind of control what do you
think happens you have to be naive to
think it doesn't happen these three
firms control roughly 80 percent out of
about four trillion dollars in total ETA
assets so if they sold you and you're
watching this you're like yeah but Pat
the whole thing but yes she is
environmental aren't they trying to make
the environment the whole purpose is to
make the world a better place so the
planet's going to be around longer no
isn't that what it's about well maybe
that's what they say but let's see if
that's what they do in December of 2021
Bloomberg found that only one of 155 ESG
upgrades of s p 500 companies cited an
actual cut in emissions as a factor
oh my God one in 155 but listen ESG what
we're doing is environmental social and
governance we're trying to make the
world a better place so you can last
longer and live longer in your kids and
the planet and all this stuff oh really
yeah show it to me what action one out
of 155. yeah you're full of I don't
believe you that's kind of how the
average person after they look at the
numbers are going to say I have a hard
time believing these guys are doing it
for a good cause Okay so so as if this
ESU stuff wasn't enough have you guys
heard about Dei or CI maybe you've heard
about you don't know a lot about it
let's too many acronyms I'm with you but
let's let's take a look at this as well
so Dei and CI take over Corporate
America according to justcapital.com as
of 2023 94 of employers and 74 percent
of workers say that their organization
has made a commitment to advancing Dei
in their workplace compared to 2021 only
32 percent of companies required some
form of VI training for their employees
you determine 94 of employers and just
two years ago was 32 percent of
companies require some sort of di
training this thing's becoming a
phenomenon right now it's cool to say we
have a Dei and a CI training I think we
even thought for like six years ago or
five years ago at first thinking this
was a good cause Okay so Dei and CI
Takeover in Corporate America there's a
few things we need to know about first
before I give you the stats here which
is absolutely wild okay so di stands for
diversity equity and inclusion refers to
organizational Frameworks which seek to
promote the fair treatment and full
participation of all people particularly
groups who have historically been under
underrepresented or subject to
discrimination on the basis of identity
or disability so sounds like a noble
cause right now let's look at CEI CI
stands for corporate equality index
which is the national benchmarking tool
on corporate policies practices and
benefits pertinent to lesbian gay
bisexual transgender and queer employees
which is kind of wild now because now
with the CI score if let's just say I'm
a 22 year old kid just got out of
college I'm working for S P 500 company
379 are participating in the CI score
138 is their first year ever what do you
think they're doing to employees like
you and I for working there what do I
have to buy it for what language do I
have to use what can't I use now here's
what's a little wild when you think
about social media sites for business
there's only one of them you think about
you think about LinkedIn right even
LinkedIn wrote an article about how this
Dei could be a bad thing for business
here's what it has to say seven ways
your di initiatives are harming your
company and how to resolve it number one
Dei is discriminatory I can imagine it
is discriminatory it's linked in saying
this number two Dei unnecessarily
preferences physical attributes over the
non-physical number three Dei diminishes
the size of the talent pool number four
di decreases performance number five di
is divisive number six di diminishes
accomplishments and disincentivizes
performance number seven Dei is
distracting says LinkedIn LinkedIn
article four ways to resolve it number
one close the DI office altogether
number two eliminate diversity quotas
number three hire promote on Merit
number four seize all diversity training
programs and reinvest that time and
money to upskill employees what a crazy
little wild little dark little no common
sense it just doesn't make any sense
what these guys are doing here by the
way do you know what the top five best
ESG score companies are number five drum
roll Bank of America I am surprised
number four Salesforce number three
Microsoft Bill and Melinda Gates
anyone's surprise I'm not surprised
number two Intel and number one highest
ESG score is a company many say that
supports the government as a company
called alphabet hence Google has a high
CSG score do you want to take a while
guess which companies have the lowest
CSU score these are anti-establishment
companies you think Tesla has a high ESG
score can you imagine Tesla does more to
actually help with emissions but to have
a medium score they're not impressive
they're right in the middle out of all
the automobile companies out of 81
automobile companies they're Rank 41.
and they're doing more than all these
other guys Twitter not the best score
Fox Nation Fox News not the best score
Xerox not the best score at T not the
best score these are at the bottom I
wonder why because they're not caving
into these ridiculous policies that
these guys are coming up with that cost
Target 9 billion the that cost but
Anheuser-Busch 15.7 billion dollars I
tweeted this the other day and I'll
explain three points I talked about
about why this doesn't work Lesson Four
Fortune 500 company CEOs and CMOS number
one screw your ESG score instead focus
on keeping your best customers happy
number two you can't please both the ESG
community and your best customers at the
same time attempting to do so will cost
you both number three it's time for the
board to fire the seal on the entire
marketing team you know what the problem
with that is the board will gladly fire
them because they're ESG people because
they own 24.9 percent of board seats in
the first place makes sense this is kind
of weird to say fire them and don't fire
them they're probably not going to fire
these guys because they're doing exactly
what they want them to do but in an
ideal situation of capitalism not
controlled by some U.N PRI score those
guys would get fired number four bad
ideas have consequences and number five
capitalism Works pandering doesn't
either going to power politics and sell
your ideas or run a company knowing your
number one customer is us then people
that work for you then these nonsense
people out of un and ESG and BlackRock
and Vanguard and State Street that
control you you work for them and the
world is starting to realize it don't
you want to be free if you do maybe talk
about it so the rest of the world can
realize what it's like to be so afraid
shivering of your ESG Dei in your CI
score anyways if you got value from the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel if you haven't watched a
video I did on George Soros who George
Soros is and another one having to do
with Hollywood both of them are linked
to ESG if you've not watched the
Hollywood Story of what they're doing
with ESG definitely watch this if you
want to know who is really the man
George Soros click here to watch this
one take care everybody bye-bye
foreign